ces flash avec cet hommage à sabine
weiss photographe 3 gueule expose ses
photographies dans l'agglomération
d'orléans ont jusqu'au 15 avril prochain
ça se passe à la collégiale saint-pierre
le peu lié au parc du foot il à olivet
et à la galerie le garage orléans cette
photographe de l'argent sera faut aux
côtés de willy ronis et robert doisneau
retrace ainsi ses expositions qui donne
un aperçu de 60 ans de photographie
enfin un travail on voit pas les
photographier tout de suite on les voit
quelques fois un mois après mais quelque
fois on se dit hassan l'âge les gelées
bien eu et quelquefois on s'est trompé
ce n'était pas aussi bien qu'on est
content qu'on l'avait imaginé tous ces
gens que j'ai photographié là je savais
que les photographier que j'avais besoin
et on pouvait discuter pourrait attendre
d'avoir une bonne expression ou de
chaque chaque chose est complètement
différente
merci pour votre fidélité à suivre
l'édition nationale passé une très belle
journée